when did you start filming the adderall
diaries
i believe
may
i filmed another movie
in new york mar
march april april may
i went straight from that movie to
another movie uh independent film with
james franco
the one i had previously shot was with
christopher walken that's right okay so
i went from one to the other
and um
saw johnny in these you know in between
like if i got a long weekend or
you know i'd fly home to be with him and
then fly back it was kind of like that
fly back from where where were you
filming those in new york okay and where
was mr depp at that time johnny was in
la at the time and then eventually
went on location for his movie black
mass in boston
so you were in new york and mr depp was
in boston at some point eventually in by
may 2014 that's it all right and what if
any discussions or arguments did you
have with mr depp relating to james
franco in that time frame of may 2014
that's a nightmare um
[Music]
i
wanted to do this independent film i
i liked the story i liked the character
i
you know told him i'm not going to wear
makeup in the thing objection hearsay
so
tell the jury what mr depp said
he was
mad at me
for taking the job with james franco he
hated
hated
james franco um and was
already accusing
me
of kind of secretly having a thing with
him in my past since we had done
pineapple express together
okay
so i'm going to take you to the boston
plain
incident we've heard about that earlier
may 24.
can you please describe for the jury
what took place on may 24
relating to
the plane incident
well i
i had spoken to johnny you know he's in
boston i'm in new york
and i spoke to him
he had already been upset with me and
accused me in
like many arguments about not
telling him about scenes that i had if i
had a kissing scene
any sort of romantic scene
and i wasn't explicit about what i was
going to do then i
was accused of having withheld
information and hiding it from him
so
i didn't want the fight of course i
didn't want the argument
but
i had to kind of
eggshell tiptoe around how to tell him
when i had any sort of scene like that
and i did
tell him in this occasion objection
hearsay
take we need to stay with what mr depp
said okay okay
so
he was upset with me um
but he didn't sound coherent
so much on the phone he was
yelling at me about how could you how
could you tell me this how could you
tell me this when i'm filming when i
have this scene that i'm doing how could
you tell me this when i'm working
obviously i couldn't tell him any other
time because we were both filming and i
told him as soon as
it was relevant and but he kept saying
how could you tell me this how could you
just tell me this
and
it was like i had told him i was having
an affair or something you know that
angry at me but he kind of started to
sound less connected to reality as these
like arguments would happen on the phone
this is in one day
eventually
he hangs up on me in the conversation
screaming screaming at me
um i talked to
his assistants i won't say what they
said but i had conversations and felt
encouraged that i could continue on with
the plan which was for me to get on the
plane go to boston
pick him up and we would go back to la
for his daughter's birthday
um
i
was nervous because the conversation i
had with him and he was so upset with me
on that conversation but i figured he'd
i assumed he had passed out
and that he would have been kind of
sobered up
the next day
assuming that the work would mean that
he felt pressured to to kind of pull it
together
and i uh get on the plane he sent the
plane so i assumed he's not that mad at
me
he's over it
we're moving on he's sobered up
um
there had been a lot of talk about a
sober plan like a full detox a full
recovery a doctor a whole plan
you know there were talks of that
following what had happened in london so
i was feeling like okay well
maybe we're here and i get on the plane
it touches down and the suv pulls up and
it sits on the tarmac for a very long
time
he knows i'm on the plane waiting for
him
so
i kind of started to anticipate that
things weren't
as i hoped meaning that he was sobering
and slipped it off
and i get
i mean i'm sitting on the plane for a
very long time waiting for him and he
finally opens the door and i
see him get out of the suv and i can
guess by how he's moving how he's
walking
i didn't realize at the time i had
already been become really sensitive to
these little changes
because my life changed depending on
what he was on
and he gets on the plane and i
um
i just knew and every cell of my body
something was wrong
and
he comes straight up to me doesn't say
anything to me but is looking at me he's
got these glasses on and he takes them
off in this kind of aggressive manner
and sits down across from me not in the
usual spot
uh we'd kind of have our
places on on this plane you know where
you get used to sitting and
i remember i got up and moved to
accommodate him getting by so he could
sit in the normal seat as per
usual
he didn't he sat across from me
at some point and i don't really
remember the exact sequence of it
we take off and at some point he
he's asking me why what's wrong with me
what do i have do i have something to
tell him do i have something to tell him
you want to talk to me about your day
yesterday and then it gets
i i already know that he's
drunk
i already know he's using
um he reeks
of weed and alcohol i mean his breath
smelled so bad and i could
i i could anticipate that there was a
no-win situation here there was no me
talking myself out of this or talking
him down or any
you know a lot of my arguments and my
involvement in them
are me trying to
diffuse by explaining or objection
non-responsive
she's telling the story you know i
i'll sustain an objectionist pardon good
so he um
is asking me questions
and i know to not engage
uh i was polite i made sure to
answer minimal amount of you know
the minimal amount that i could i moved
slowly i was trying to be polite but not
engaged because there was no win and he
kept
going kept asking me eventually went
from do you have something to tell me to
you want to tell me how much you liked
it
tell me did he slip a tongue
it got worse and worse just more it went
from asking me about how my kissing
scene went or how the sex scene went to
asking me what james franco had done in
the scene
to being really explicit about
my body
you know he was talking about
my
he was saying
really disgusting things
about my body
about how i liked it
how i responded and then he started
talking just straight up taunting me i i
know you liked it he called me a
go-getter
he called me a [ __ ]
in front and also this is happening with
security
and his assistance on the plane and
i remember i felt
i
i
i don't i don't
i struggled to
to
be able to tell you how
how embarrassed i was because he was
speaking to me in front of people in
this way
asking me if i liked it and if i was wet
and
you know why i wasn't looking at him and
that was proof i wasn't looking at him
that was proof that i that i was asking
for did i ask
james to do this and this to me and how
about if he does those things to me
ex
insert
sexually explicit descriptions of
what he
accused me of
wanting or deserving
and i at some point in this get up
and move to the front of the planet i
remember getting up so slowly
i didn't want to aggravate him i didn't
want to give him any excuse to pounce on
i didn't want to upset him i didn't want
him
to
flip a switch and get worse i didn't
want i just remember
very slow movements and i slowly get up
and move to the front of the plane and
he starts throwing things at me ice
cubes utensils
he's calling me a um
a go-getter and then an embarrassment
talking about what an embarrassment i am
i don't know how many times i move seats
i wish i did
i don't i remember moving more than once
and johnny came to me each time not the
other way around
he sits down in front of me at one point
and
because i'm not answering him i was
looking out of the window and he slaps
my face
and
his
friend
is in our proximity
and i
it didn't hurt me it didn't hurt my face
it just felt embarrassed
did you do that to me in front of people
it was the first time that anything like
that had happened in front of somebody
i got up
to move again and he's just taunting me
having a laugh screaming
and then just straight up me and calling
me names
and it was oscillating between those
things and i get up
slowly again and i just
resolve to just sit the rest of the time
up at the front of the plane
and
as i get up
he kind of kicks the swivel chair into
my hip but kind of just hits me
and i look at him
and he asks me what what are you gonna
do about it
we
i just stared at him
i just stared
at him and
wanted him to see me i wanted to get
through to him didn't feel there was
like i it felt like there was a
blackness in his eyes i wanted to look
at him i wanted him to see me it didn't
even feel like him
and
as i'm walking away
slowly trying not to be i was being very
deliberate about my movements
wasn't saying anything i wasn't engaging
i am walking away from him slowly and he
tells me to hurry the [ __ ] up
hurry up
and i just
look at him one more time
wanting to penetrate the monster to see
the man that i love underneath that
the man i loved
and he tells me to hurry up
again and i pull my gaze away from him i
walk away from him
my back is turned to him and i feel this
boot
in my back
it just kicked me
in the back
i
fell to the floor i caught myself on the
floor and i just felt like i was looking
at the
floor of the plane for
felt like a long time
and i didn't i thought to myself
i don't know what to do
i can't believe he just did he just
kicked me
no one said anything no one did anything
it was like you could
you could hear a pin drop on that plane
you could feel the tension but no one
did anything
and i just remember feeling so
embarrassed
i felt so embarrassed that he could kick
me to the ground
in front of people
and not be more embarrassing i didn't
know what to do about it i got up and i
just i walked to the front of the plane
i sat down
and i just
looked out of the window